مساء الخير احيانا بيتم الاشاره الى حرب
اليمن اللي بقى لها حوالي 21 شهر في وسائل
الاعلام الغربيه باعتبارها الحرب المنسيه
هم بيقولوا هي حرب منسيه لانها لا تحظى
بالتغطيه الاعلاميه الكافيه مقارنه
بالصراعات المماثله في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
زي سوريا وزي العراق وزي ليبيا لكن اللي
ما بيقولش ليه هي حرب منسيه الحقيقه في
ثلاث اسباب بتخلي حرب اليمن اقل تحظى
باهتمام اقل خصوصا على المستوى الدولي
السبب الاولاني
انه الدول
الغربيه صحيح مصالحها تاثرت قليلا بالحرب
لكن مصالحها الاساسيه الممثله في العبور
من باب المندب
والمتمثله يعني في
احتواء القاعده والحرب على الارهاب وانت
اثرت لك ليست كثيرا والمرور من باب المندب
ما زال قائما دون ان تتاثر حرجه التجاره
العالميه فده اول سبب السبب
الثاني انه بعض هذه الدول يخاف غضب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي قد تعاقبهم
اقتصاديا انهم تمادوا اكثر مما ينبغي في
عرض الصوره في اليمن بشكل يضر بصوره
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامر الثالث
وهو الاهم ان كثير من الدول دي هو متورد
بالفعل في الحرب اما بشكل مباشر بدعم
المملكه لوجستيا وا استخباراتيا او وهو
الاهم ببيع السلاح للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهم غير راغبين في تسليط الضوء
من خلال وسائل الاعلام الاساسيه اللي
بيسيطر عليها الغرب لان دوت معناها انه
هيعرض الى احراق شديد ويجرح الصوره
الذهنيه اللي بيحبوا يرسموها امام شعوبهم
باعتبارهم زعماء العالم الحر يعني يجنوا
ثمار الحرب في شكل عقود سلاح بريطانيا
لوحدها باعت الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اسلحه منذ انطلاق حرب اليمن والى الان ب 2
وث من مليار دولار لكن في نفس الوقت يحبوا
ان يزرف دموع التماسيح على الضحايا ما
يحبوش انه يبانوا في الصوره بانهم جزء من
هذه الماساه عموما هذه قصه اخرى احنا
النهارده نكلم على مساله ابسط من كده شويه
احنا بناء على رغبه عدد من اصدقائنا ومنهم
صديقنا مصطفى ابو زيد اللي طلب اكثر من
مره ان احنا نعرض الى حرب اليمن بنقول
امرين كيف بدات الحرب والاطراف الاساسيه
المشاركه الان والاهم من كل ده افق الحل
او السناريوهات المحتمله لنهايه الحرب
الحرب بنذكر
بدات بشكل يبدو ان هو عفوي لما الرئيس
هادي قرر تحت ضغوط صندوق النقد الدولي رفع
اسعار الوقود والحقيقه انه عمل كده لانه
اليمن وهي افقر دوله في العالم العربي
واحده من افقر دول العالم كانت على شفا
الافلاس طيب لما لما رفع الرئيس هادي
الدعم عن الوقود خف خفف الدعم عن الوقود
وبالتالي ارتفعت الاسعار في جمعات كثيره
ثارت غضبا على هذه الخطوه لكن اللي تصدر
المشهد كان جماعه انصار الله او المعروفين
اعلاميا بالحوثيين الحقيقه الحوثيين ربما
كانوا غاضبين من رفع الاسعار لكن مش هو ده
ابدا السبب الرئيسي الغضب اللي كان لدى
جماعه الحوثيين على وجه التحديد هو
الحقيقه بيعبر عن غضب واحباط مستمر منذ
سنوات طويله لدى الجماعه اللي بتمثل
اغلبيه في منطقه صعده في شمال اليمن وجنوب
السعوديه وبتمثل اقليه طبعا يعني ك طائفه
كطائفة كبيرا في اليمن شجع الحوثيين على
ان هم يلعبوا دور
اكبر مع اندلاع الانتفاضات والغضب بسبب
اللي انا قلت لحضراتكم عليه الاعتراض على
قرارات
الرئيس تلى ذلك تحزب بين قوى كثيره على
راسها في ذلك الوقت جماعه الحوثيين وقوى
اخرى متعاطفه معاهم او مشتركه معاهم في
الغضب على ضعف حكومه هادي وقراراته و
حكومه هادي ومعه قوه اخرى اهمها حزب
الاصلاح او جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
اليمنيين حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا كان في قوه
مؤثره جدا ومهمه تنتظر وتراقب وبتنتف
اللحظه المناسبه لتحقيق مصالحها وهو
الرئيس علي عبد الله صالح نفسه اللي خرج
من السلطه مرغما بضغط دولي وضغط محلي
ولعبت دول الخليج دور كبير جدا في اقناعه
عن التخلي عن السلطه بعد 2011 بعد ان
تعهدت له ب تحصينه قضائيا من
الملاحقه في كل الاحوال اللي حصل انه
المفاوضات التي تلت هذه الانتفاضات
ومحاوله ارضاء جماعه الحوثيين التي كانت
بتطالب بخفض اسعار الوقود وحكومه جديده ثم
تطورت المساله الى اجتماعات كثيره جدا بين
كل الفرقاء في محاوله لصياغه دستور جديد
يضمن اشراك الجميع في السلطه فشلت كل هذه
المفاوضات وكان من الطبيعي ان هي تفشل لان
انه القوى الاقوى على الارض وقتها كانت
جماعه الحوثيين وانصارهم ومن وراهم الرئيس
اليمني علي عبد الله صالح اللي حكم من سنه
78 حتى عام
2011 انتهت المساله بانه الحوثيين راوا
انه المجال مفتوح امامهم مع انسداد
الافق لجاوا الى استخدام القوه اللي هي
مفتوحه واستخدموا وجدوا المجال خالي اليهم
ومتاح فاستولوا على صنعاء ولم يكتفوا
بصنعاء وكمان اتجهوا الى عدن مما اضطر
الرئيس اليمني هادي الى الفرار لاجئا الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وقتها وجدت
السعوديه نفسها في مازق ان هي صبرت على
الموقف الجاري ده معناه انه جماعه
الحوثيين سوف تكون القوى الرئيسيه في
اليمن وان لم تستحوذ على كامل اليمن فسوف
تستحوذ على قطاع مقدم منه ولان السعوديه
كانت وما زالت تعتقد ان جماعه انصار الله
هم ذراع اخرى لايران في المنطقه مماثل الى
حزب الله في لبنان او مماثل الى بشار
الاسد في دمشق
وا وعدد من القوى اللي موجوده من
الميليشيات اللي موجوده في العراق
وابتدع او الجماعات المسلحه في العراق
اللي بتدع ايران فكان بالنسبه لها هاجس
شديد جدا وضغط او خطر شديد من وجهه نظرها
على امنها القومي الا تكون محاصره من كل
الجوانب شمالا وجنوبا وشرقا وغربا بجماعات
مدعومه من ايران فقررت في مارس
2015 انها تشن عمليه
عسكريه يبدو ان كانت حساباتها انها تكون
عمليه عسكريه سريعه مدعومه من اطراف دوليه
مختلفه عربيا ودوليا بحيث انها تعيد كل
الاطراف المارقه وتحديدا جماعه انصار الله
الى رشدهم بحيث يجلسوا الى مائده مفاوضات
مع الحكومه الشرعيه اي المعترف بها دوليا
اللي هي حكومه الرئيس هادي المدعومه من
السعوديه لكن خلال 21 شهر لم يحدث ذلك
وتحولت الحرب الى ماسال
لليمنيين بعد ان تم تشريد الملايين وتحولت
الاوضاع هناك الى كارثه انسانيه ووفقا
للامم المتحده ان كل 10 دقائق طفل يمني
يموت وعادت اليمن اللي هي بالفعل افقر
دوله في العالم العربي الى عشرات السنوات
الى الخلف وانتهاء الحرب الان يعني ان
العراق ان اليمن يحتاج سنوات طويله جدا
حتى يعود الى نقطه البدايه التي كانت
شريده السوء في حال انها وجدت
تمويل والوضع القائم الان ايه هي القوه
اللي المتحاربه بعد مرور 21 شهر هي نفس
القوه التي بدات مع تغيرات بسيطه هنجد ان
الحوثيين مازالوا حتى هذه اللحظه
بيحافظوا محتلين الى صنعاء او مسيطرين على
صنعاء بنجد انه التحالف الدولي اللي بتقو
يعني الجيش اليمني او ما تبقى من الجيش
اليمني اللي بيدعم لان الجيش اليمني انقسم
اثناء هذا الفتنه الكبيره ما بين جزء منه
ظل على تاييده للرئيس الشرعي هادي ومعاهم
بعض القوى
الجنوبيه اللي بتدعم الرئيس هادي يعني
اليمن الجنوبي سابقا اللي كان بيسمى اليمن
الجنوبي واللي اصبح جزء من اليمن بعد
الحرب بعد اعلان الاندماج بين اليمنين في
سنه
1990 وطبعا وجزء ثاني انضم الى الحوثيين
والرئيس علي عبد الله صالح
اللي انضم الى جماعه انصار الله في هذه
الم المركه فاصبح عندنا من ناحيه الحوثيين
علي عبد الله صالح وقطع من الجيش الرئيس
هادي
ومعه قوه يمنيه وطبعا ومعه جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في اشكال مختلفه يعني تحت اسماء
مختلفه وفي نفس الوقت هو ده القوى اللي
بيدعو التحالف اللي بتقو السعوديه خلاف
القوتين
دول اللي غير قادرين على حسم المعركه
خصوصا انه تحالف يكتفي فقط بضربات جويه
دون وجود قوه على الارض بخلاف قوات الجيش
اليمني غير قادره على حسم المعركه ا على
الارض عندنا كمان قوه استفادت جدا من
الفراغ اللي موجود وهذه القوى متمثله في
جماعه القاعده اذا كان اسمها جماعه
القاعده في شبه جزيره العربيه الجزيره
العربيه او انصار الشريعه ايا كان الاسم
واصبحوا عندهم دويله داخل دويلات يمن
لانهم بيسيطر على حوالي 350 ميل على جزيره
على خليج عدن وبيمر سوا هوايتهم زي ما حصل
مؤخرا في تفجير الجنود اليمنيين ومساجد
الحوثيين
واكتسبوا مزيد من الشعبيه لانه مع صعود
جماعه الحوثيين المحسوبين على
الشيعه اصبحت هذه الجماعات المتغلغل في
عدد من القبائل اليمنيه بتحاول تصور
صراعها مع الحوثيين ب اعتباره صراع طائفي
ما بين سنه وشيعه وطبعا بتبرر ضربها لقوات
يمنيه باعتبارهم انه هم يعني دول
حراس
يعني الطاغوت او المستبدين فهي بتستهدف
الاثنين الغريبه انه في اليمن بيتسابق
جامعتين متشابهتين يعني داعش او الدوله
الاسلاميه المسماه بالدوله الاسلاميه
والقاعده التقديرات بتقول ان داعش هناك
بالمئات لكن القاعده هناك بالالاف فاصبح
عندنا زادت الحرب زادت الحرب وجود
الجماعات المتطرفه بشده ودوت بيثير قلق
الدول الغربيه اكتر واللي تمثل مؤخرا في
ان الولايات المتحده اللي عاوزه تنفض
ايدها من الحرب وتضغط على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اعلنت في حركه كده زي دونك شت
كده حركه تبدو بطوليه سوف نوقف دعمكم
بالسلاح واحنا دعمنا لكم مش على ا يعني
شيك على بياض ولو تتذكروا في يناير
2016 اللي هو العام الماضي لما عملنا حلقه
عن توقعاتنا في 2016 كنا بنقول من بين
الاحتمالات هل يمكن ان تتخلى الولايات
المتحده على السعوديه في حربها على اليمن
بهدف استنزافها واقع الامر انها بتمه الان
الى هذه الخطوه وواقع الامر ان السعوديه
تبحث عن مخرج من الحرب لكنها غير قادره
على على الخ خروج الان لان مافيش اي من
الاطراف عاوز يساعدها على خروج امن يحفظ
ما وجهها ويحقق مصالحها او جزء من مصالحها
الحروب اللي زي حرب اليمن بتنتهي يا اما
الحروب اي الحروب يا بتنتهي بانتصار كاسح
لاحد الاطراف على الطرف الاخر فتنتهي
باستسلام زي ما حصل في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه في بالنسبه لليابان او حتى هزه
الالمان في الحرب العالميه الاولى او
باتفاق الطرفين اللي بتنهج الحرب على نقطه
وسط وبالتالي تبقى في معاهده سلام زي ما
حصل في حرب الرمال ما بين الجزائر والمغرب
في الستينات او حتى بين مصر واسرائيل في
السبعينات او يحصل ان الطرف القوي والاكبر
والمسيطر هو اللي يضطر ينهي الحرب تحت اي
ذريعه حفاظا على ماء وجهه واحتواء للخسائر
الضخمه الماليه والعسكريه والسياسيه امام
المجتمع الدولي والسعوديه تبحث عن حل من
هذه الحلول يحافظ على مصالحها ويحفظ ما
وجهها لكن يبدو ان
الحوثيين اللي ادركوا ان الضغوط تزيد على
السعوديه ويبدو انه بمنطق اننا بالفعل
تحملنا خسائر كثيره لا يريدون ان يمنحوا
السعوديه هذه الفرصه ما يعقد الوضع اكثر
واكثر ويجعل من وجود حل في الافق غير
قائم اشكركم والى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله